repeal now and replace later that's
president Trump's suggestion to break
the Senate impasse to overhaul the
affordable care act but last night
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
said the chamber would continue to stick
with its bill which would simultaneously
rollback Obamacare and offer a
replacement Republican leaders and mr.
Trump considered the idea of two
separate bills some months ago but then
dismissed it as unworkable mr. Trump is
spending the holiday weekend at his New
Jersey golf course Paula Reid is
traveling with the president Paula good
morning good morning
the president's change in direction on
his health care policy came via Twitter
amid a new controversy over his mocking
of two TV hosts and all of this happened
at the same time the White House was
hosting the president of South Korea the
year of strategic patience with the
North Korean regime has failed
many years and it's failed and frankly
that patience is over standing with
South Korean president moon jae-in
president Trump said the u.s. is working
closely with South Korea as North Korea
makes progress towards a nuclear-tipped
missile that could hit the u.s. the
president declined to elaborate Friday
on his tweet that if Republican senators
are unable to pass what they are working
on now they should immediately repeal
and then replace at a later date it'll
be repeal and replace it will be
essentially simultaneously but it
suggests a stark departure for the
president who in January insisted that
Obamacare be repealed and replaced at
the same time it will be various
segments you understand but will most
likely be on the same day or the same
week but probably the same day could be
the same hour it's an approach that
could rally president Trump's Republican
base as Congress begins its July 4th
recess and it echoes a letter sent from
senator Ben Sasse to the President on
Friday calling for a plan B if no
agreement next week repeal first and
spend August on replace
President Trump also ignored another
question over his public squabble with
MSNBC anchors Mika Brzezinski and Joe
Scarborough in a Washington Post op-ed
headline Donald Trump is not well the
two wrote that White House aides tried
to intimidate them with a negative story
in the National Enquirer and they said
if you call the president up and he will
apologize for your coverage then he will
pick up the phone and basically spike
this story mr. Trump is longtime friends
with David Packer CEO of American media
that publishes the tabloid in response
to the allegation the president tweeted
it was Scarborough who called him to
stop the article I said no sources tell
CBS News that Scarborough reached out to
the president's son-in-law Jared Kushner
in April about a National Inquirer story
and that at some point in that
conversation Kushner suggested that an
apology to the president could prompt
him to intervene the National Enquirer
says it has no knowledge of these
conversations between the White House
and the TV hosts Anthony Paula Reid
thanks Paul